you know that is a challenge and every
artist has to figure out the right
balance you don't want to represent a
brand that that dishonours your name
that that cheapens you but you also know
that in this climate you know with
records record sales going down and with
record label spending a lot less money
on marketing we need to find other
marketing partners to to get our music
out and so I've entered into strategic
partnerships with different leg with
different brands in order to get my
music out to the people and I only do it
with brands that I think reflect well on
me and that respect my fans and my music
and want to put out messages that are
consistent with music and with I think
the taste of my thing